I am doing this in person with actual
live people
um so this is the time of year when we
do our annual well from summer school
um well from Summer research program for
high school students and so we actually
have uh people from our summer school
here
um and we'll take questions both locally
and uh uh from the um uh uh from uh from
from the uh from the outside world so to
speak
um so
I have a question
here from Aaron can you comment on the
future of llms being running in the
cloud versus running almost local
machine that's a that's in terms of the
the span of futurology that we discuss
that's comparatively near term but it's
an important one because it's really a
question of to what extent is sort of
the AI of the near future going to be
kind of a centralized Collective Ai and
to what extent it's going to be a
personal individualized AI
um the uh
um
um the the
um so that that's some
uh that's that's that's sort of what
this what the nub of this question is
are we going to have our own you know
independent llms running on our own
machines or is it going to be the case
that only the big sort of uh Power
Station scale llm uh can be a thing that
we can use uh my guess is that it will
get more and more localized and you know
what are the what are the constraining
factors you know one thing is what's the
training data the training data that's
been used so far as about four billion
web pages and a bunch of a few million
uh scanned books question is what's out
there what could you train on and and
the answer is in terms of textual
material the uh there's probably you
know in in the archive text of the web
there's probably 60 billion web pages
um perhaps in the in the deeper web
there might be a couple hundred million
web page a couple hundred billion web
pages in terms of books The General
General estimate is that maybe 150
billion 150 million books in the world
so to speak
um so it's it's you know it's a factor
of uh uh 10 20 30 larger than the
current training data but not much more
than that it's not um you know that
that's not a need for for sort of much
bigger things than than we have today
now uh you know there will be training
on videos there's a huge amount more
video in the world and just in terms of
bits than there is uh uh text but it's
not clear that that uh the sort of the
condensed version of that that's
relevant for an Ln it's not clear how
big that is but that's sort of the first
thing is is the training data well you
know on our machines it's it's sort of
an interesting thing when the web was
younger I was kind of expecting that
people would routinely have a copy of
the web locally and actually with common
crawl and things like that you know I
have a copy of the web in my basement or
something in in uh you know on on some
server it's not it's not so big you
can't have it
um it's not so useful because you have
to store the index the index is
comparable in size to the the um the
actual uh um the actual web and to do
fast searching you have to have the
index in memory and that's right now an
expensive thing to achieve so I think
that's that's kind of a kind of an issue
for that I think that the um
the way that um uh the kind of the the
current dynamics of of llms uh you kind
of have to you know they're quite big
like chat gbt is 175 billion weights
that's 175 billion uh uh machine
floating Point numbers
um and that uh and and you have to it's
good to have that in memory a lot of the
pieces of the computation get done in
parallel and gpus
um those are those are kind of the um uh
um
the things one's doing there I think
there's a sort of a question of does the
llm need those 175 billion weights let's
question what the lln is doing you know
with an llm connected to our technology
stack uh you kind of don't need the llm
to be able to know all these facts about
the world the llm needs to have common
sense knowledge of the world and it
needs to have sort of linguistic
knowledge but it doesn't need to know
the specific population of the city of
Boston and so on that's stuff that can
come as a separate kind of computational
tool so to speak so my guess is that
that one of the things that will be
coming and a bunch of people I know are
working on this is kind of the
distillation of llams to be purely a
linguistic linguistic interface layer
and a common sense layer you need a
certain amount of common sense to be
able to provide a good linguistic
interface but all the fact stuff and all
the computation stuff will be kind of
outsourced to things like our technology
stack which is would which are not uh
where it's a a different thing and you
don't need that to be be part of the llm
so it is my my guess would be that um uh
we'll we'll see uh much smaller llms
that are as linguistically capable as
what we have right now but where the
facts are coming from elsewhere that
that's that that would be my guess and I
think that's important in in kind of the
the uh both societal dynamics of AI and
so on the societal Dynamics is very
different if there's one Central AI you
know one particular company controls it
one government controls it whatever else
versus everybody has it on their own
separate computer and that's been a
thing that's been played out a bunch of
times in kind of the history of
different kinds of Technologies whether
you know there's a central printing
press where everybody knows where the
printing press is versus everybody has
their own laser printer those are those
are different Dynamics and they've
they've played out differently in terms
of the kinds of controls that there can
be on your the printing process let's
say in that particular case
let's see the um
another question from Aaron
um uh who is actually here and uh who
has contributed to live streams in the
past remotely and it's been it's been
great to actually meet a person who I've
only sort of seen the handle of and in
live streams but anyway Aaron asks um
does the nanograph discovery spark ideas
for experimental validation of a physics
project okay so to explain that uh
about gravitational waves and what is
what are gravitational waves in kind of
the the standard kind of theory of
space-time that's existed since 1915
general relativity the kind of the idea
is that space has a kind of uh has
enough structure to be able to have
things like curvature that space is not
just completely featureless it can have
it can have curvature which varies
between different positions in space and
one feature of that curvature is you can
have gravitational waves just like you
can have waves and you know water waves
or something like this gravitational
waves are produced whenever massive
bodies get kind of squidged I say
squidged because the actual thing that
happens is the title the actual sort of
minimal way of making a gravitational
wave involves a tidal deformation where
you are sort of squashing in One
Direction and expanding in the other
direction it's a little different for
electromagnetism you can just have an
electron going up and down a dipole
antenna and that will make an
electromagnetic wave but for
gravitational waves you need this kind
of quadrupole squidging uh you know
tidal deformation but so lots of things
effectively have that even a planet or
Star orbiting an orbit will emit
gravitational waves
um but the most uh the most dramatic
gravitational waves come from uh the
merger of black holes and for a long
time it wasn't known whether black
whether gravitational waves would be
they hadn't been detected they were
first detected when around 2015 I think
um by the ligo gravitational wave
detectors there are two in the US One in
Louisiana one in Washington state
um and they're they're things which
basically are just sort of trying to
measure the effective distance in space
in space and they're trying to see sort
of deformations in the structure of
space which they have to do by having
very precise kind of Machinery that's
measuring sort of deformations to within
a fraction of the size of an atom and so
when when every you know every week or
so somewhere in the universe two black
holes will have been and kind of
captured a binary star and they will
merge in a sort of dramatic event which
will release as much energy as will be
released by taking the Sun for example
and converting it all into uh all into
sort of uh energy like photons and so on
um and part of that energy is released
as gravitational waves and pretty much
everywhere in the universe if if a black
hole merger occurs we can now detect it
with gravitational wave detectors but
those detectors it takes you know when
you when you see these gravitational
waves they have a certain frequency and
you see and and you see them kind of
wiggling the structure of space-time as
a result of what's happening in these
black holes somewhere Across the
Universe
well there's uh there's a uh kind of a
experiment people have proposed that's
looking for low frequency gravitational
waves gravitational waves where the
frequency could be as low as sort of one
wiggle per hour or day or year
um where much lower frequency and turns
out there's a nice way to measure that
which is to look at the timing of
pulsars so pulsars are neutron stars
that are rotating and they have magnetic
fields and they have these kind of uh
sort of Spotlight beams of radio energy
that they send out whenever the whenever
the Pulsar has rotated around to that
orientation so that the beam is pointing
at us we get to sort of hear that radio
pulse and if you if you kind of listen
to the audio version of a pulsar it'll
make a kind of
type noise at least the fast ones make
that kind of noise as you kind of hear
that um uh that radio pulse kind of that
from the beacon that's kind of the
spotlight that is hitting uh in our
Direction so to speak so okay there are
a bunch of pulsars that um
uh rotate rapidly there are pulsars that
um uh rotate even as fast as a thousand
times a second the original Power stars
that was discovered in 1968 are um uh
pulsars that were periods of around a
second I think people thought it was
really weird when they first discovered
pulsars it's like this must be a beacon
from extraterrestrials because what
could possibly make this sort of
periodic signal that that quickly and it
turned out it was just physics just a
neutron star whether you decide that a
neutron star is really like an example
of extraterrestrial intelligence that's
a different issue but uh it is at least
we can account for it in physics
as perhaps we can account for what
happens in our brains physically as well
in any case pulsars they have this
feature that they um uh um
have um uh that that
um they they they produce these beams of
radio energy and that they're spinning
around very rapidly you know a pulsar is
a neutron star is a collapsed star so
you take the whole mass of something a
bit heavier than the sun even and you
crush it down into something that's 10
kilometers across it's the density of an
atomic nucleus around 10 to the 14 uh uh
times the density of water and uh that
thing is a very you know it has a it's
like a top spinning around and it really
spins very accurately and so the timing
of pulsars is is very accurately
determined sometimes there are kind of
uh sort of quakes in the neutron star
the the neutron uh you'll you'll get the
analog of earthquakes and the neutron
star and those make little glitches but
basically the timing of pulse size is
very accurate but if the structure of
space is deformed so that the you have
uh sort of a gravitational field goes
through when gravitational fields the
presence of a gravitational field
changes the rate at which time
progresses in our physics project we can
kind of understand how this works it's
kind of when there is sort of more
gravitational field more curvature in
space gravitational fields associated
with curvature in space uh kind of there
are more updates to the structure of
space to maintain the structure of space
then you can kind of then then
effectively the the rate at which time
is perceived to progress goes down and
so the same thing happens for a pulsar
that when the gravitational wave goes
through changes the gravitational uh it
changes the amount of gravity so to
speak changes the effective way in which
time passes and it will change the the
rate of the the pulsars uh uh the the
rate at which the the pulses come from
the Pulsar so there's this experiment
was done over the last 10 15 years
um that recently announced some results
although the results were not as clearly
kind of enunciated as one might have
hoped that um the uh that somehow we're
looking at I know 60 or so pulsars at
different places around around the uh uh
the Galaxy
um that um
that one could tell that there were
potentially tell that there were
gravitational waves that were of low
frequency very long wavelength waves
were just like a giant water wave that
kind of uh slowly changes from from
being a Crest to a trough and so on that
these were kind of going through this
this array of pulsars and and showing
gravitational waves so the um the thing
that uh uh that that that the question
is okay if they're a low frequency
gravitational waves where did they come
from did they come from the early
Universe most likely were they the
result of kind of the fact that the
early Universe wasn't a perfectly
spherical kind of thing it was a thing
that had kind of imperfections and those
imperfections led to things like these
gravitational waves well I think in our
physics project one of the things that's
really sort of different is the idea
that space is not just a
three-dimensional thing that the the
dimension of space is a dynamical
variable space in our view of things in
the case of general relativity space got
enough structure to have things like
curvature in our model space really does
have structure all the way down it's
like a fluid like water that's made of
molecules in our case space is made of
atoms of space it's a giant network of
atoms of space and actually the thing I
have projected on the screen behind me
here is a is a very toy example of of
kind of a network that represents the
potential sort of connectivity of atoms
of space one feature of networks like
that is they don't have an intrinsic
Dimension they don't have a there are X
and Y and Z coordinates rather starting
from a given point you can say you can
kind of go out on the network in
different directions and you ask the
question how many places can you get to
when you go a certain distance out on
the network and depending on sort of how
fast that grows that gives you a sense
of the dimension of the network but the
effective dimension of the network but
the dimension can change and so for
example in the early Universe we think
the dimensions started essentially as
infinite and gradually kind of cooled
down to being the three dimensions that
we now observe and I think that uh that
phenomenon of the sort of the the the
cooling down from this infinite
dimensional State there are undoubtedly
Dimension fluctuations left over places
where you know the effective dimension
of space-time is 3.01 or 2.99 or
whatever and I think it is quite likely
that there is a way to detect that fact
the idea of Dimension fluctuations if
they're on sort of the same kind of
length scales as the kinds of
gravitational waves that are detected by
the Pulsar timing array that is quite
conceivable that one might see the
effects of Dimension fluctuations in a
case like that which would be really
exciting and really you know the thing
that that we're we're you know there was
this argument for so long about whether
matter was discrete or continuous that's
an argument that went on from Antiquity
and that finally that argument got
resolved at the beginning of the 20th
Century basically by observing little
things like brown in motion where you
can in a in a in some water or something
have little pieces of that come from
pollen grains and under a microscope you
can just see things discreetly kicking
those grains around and those discrete
kicks are individual impacts of water
molecules and so we can tell from that
that's kind of the final thing that says
yes you know water is made of discrete
things it isn't a purely continuous
fluid now the challenge is can we see
the same thing for space-time We Believe
forever that space time is basically
continuous can we can we see the analog
of Brownian motion in space-time and
that's kind of a big challenge that's
the thing that is really interesting to
try and see with our models of physics I
think you know it's it's if we see
dimensional fluctuations we see uh kind
of discreetness evidence of discreetness
and space-time I think uh I mean I have
to say that for me our physics project
has fit together so elegantly that I
just it's sort of an inevitable thing it
has to work that way but I think in
terms of the kind of uh look you know
here's an experiment that you just can't
explain any other way the the
observation of of discreetness and
space-time sort of an analog about
emotion space-time the analog of the the
observation of Dimension fluctuations
will be very striking and you know we
don't know how big the dimension
fluctuations will be just like we don't
know how big kind of the other things
left over from the early Universe how
much variation in the densities of
things or the curvature of space-time or
these gravitational waves will be left
over from the other Universe we also
don't know what kind of Dimension
fluctuations will be left over so we
can't predict that but even the very
phenomenon of a dimension fluctuation is
totally weird from the point of view of
of uh normal kind of thinking about
physics I mean it's kind of like if you
do calculus you know which is sort of
the study of of how things change and so
on you might do univariate calculus one
variable one thing is changing and then
you might if you do a more advanced
class you might do multivariate calculus
when you talk about you know X and Y and
Z can all be changing but what you never
get to talk about is fractional
dimensional space-time fractional
Dimension fractional number of variables
so to speak where you have not X and Y
and Z were three variables but you have
2.95 variables that's just not something
one gets to talk about it's something
for in our physics project that we're
working hard to try and sort of build
the mathematics to understand those
kinds of things
so uh let's see
question here from Dugan also in person
um can you discuss the next Evolution
for AI models so far we have language
models image to text text to image
Etc
I think the next really obvious one is
video and you know one's starting to see
some experiments with that there's an
awful lot about sort of how the world
works that is captured in gazillions of
hours of videos that are available and I
think that will be a place where uh one
can learn things about how the world
works that have not been readily
learnable from text you know picture is
worth more than a thousand words
probably and a video is worth even more
than that and I think that will be a big
big thing video generation will also be
a thing
um I think uh exactly how that will be
used I'm not sure I mean you know people
think about you know the the uh like the
Apple headset thing has this way of
detecting you know has a cameras inward
facing cameras that can see your eyes
and so on I think they have a a plan
that they announced to have kind of
video conferencing where both people are
wearing these headsets and so if you
looked at them in reality so to speak in
outside from a camera you'd see these
people with the great big headsets on
but you can kind of synthesize something
that's kind of like what that person's
face will be looking like just by those
inward facing cameras even though
there's headset over a bunch of parts of
that face I don't know how weird that
will be and whether that will be
wonderful or just weird
um I think that so video generation
there's surely lots of examples where
that will be that will become a thing I
think the thing to understand about
something like video is it's kind of
like the progressive evolution of user
interfaces you know in in when we first
started dealing with computers we had
just textual interfaces where we typed
certain commands then we got things like
graphical user interfaces where we were
kind of looking at where we were having
menus and we were being able to select
things and so on the thing that is sort
of dramatic with large language models
and chat gbt and so on is this idea of a
linguistic user interface we we I would
say kind of pioneered that with wolf
Alpha where way you could have in wolfen
Alpha you can ask a short question in
pure natural language and have it
converted to computational language and
then answered but chat gbt and so on can
deal with generating large amounts of
text and potentially breaking down large
amount of text to see what were you
talking about so this kind of idea of a
Louis a linguistic user interface is
something that's kind of a a new thing
made possible by llms so I'm sure that
there'll be you know vui's video user
interfaces so to speak where where both
the inputs of the machine is kind of a
video of you yakking as I am now at the
machine and the output from the machine
will be a generated video of some Avatar
kind of uh uh you know talking to you so
to speak and I'm sure that will come I
don't know uh you know it's always
interesting to see kind of how that how
well that works
um but but that's that's the kind of
thing I would imagine will come also
lots of virtual world kind of capable
abilities I'm not sure you know I think
the jury is still out on how much people
like virtual worlds in general I think
you know post pandemic after we were all
virtual for a while I mean I've been a
remote CEO for 32 years now so I've been
sort of a little bit virtualized at the
best of times but but uh you know we
were all virtual for a while and now it
turns out it seems like it's kind of fun
to actually be in person like at our
summer school that we're we're doing now
and I'm not sure that the the kind of
the the everything's going to get
virtualized and generated by AI for
videos and so on is is necessarily the
the thing people are going to like I
mean the thing we have to understand
about sort of the progression of AI is
much as computationally possible but
only a certain amount of that is what we
humans care about and feel comfortable
with I mean we can go out into the sort
of computational Universe of possible
programs we can make all kinds of stuff
like the thing that's behind me for
example but then you say well is that a
humanized thing is that something that
sort of relates to something human and
it may or may not be and sort of the the
question of what works for us humans as
a kind of human user interface is uh is
something that uh you know kind of we we
it's it's a it's a different kind of
question from what is computationally
possible so I mean I think there's
there's that side of things the the
video user interface that will come I
think uh you know eventually they'll be
neural neural user interfaces from you
know various kinds of neural implant
like things and that will be a whole
nother area you know that one of the
things that's already being done to some
extent with machine learning is you know
you if you sever some peripheral nerve
you can end up with you know being able
to have some sort of learning of what
what the uh what to do based on nerve
signals from that and I suspect that you
know eventually there'll be those kinds
of things that's a sort of a different
level of of user interface so I think
you know those those kinds of interfaces
will will be there another big area is
Robotics and actually being able to
actuate in the world so to speak
um and uh I'd say two things but first
actuating in the world actually
wandering around sort of seeing the
environment having lidar and things to
figure out the three-dimensional
structure of the environment that's one
thing the other is sensor Nets in
general I mean we with our human senses
we're used to being kind of in one place
we've got our ears our eyes they're kind
of within a few centimeters of each
other and uh you know we get to sense
certain kinds of things we have a
certain amount of sort of distributed
sensing from touch on our skin and
things like this but you can imagine you
know a sensor Network where you've got a
million sensors distributed on a you
know over a over a you know thousand
square mile area and they're all picking
up different kinds of things so that's
kind of like a a way it's like a like a
skin you know like the the touch sensors
on a skin but they're extended out over
a thousand square miles and and that's
the thing from which we can learn you
know kind of our our sensing of the
world becomes a different kind kind of
thing when we have those kinds of those
kinds of inputs and I think that's
another thing we'll see kind of we don't
completely know what to do with those
things and you know kind of
understanding how that works is is
another thing that I suspect is coming
as a domain for AI I mean I think in in
general the you know the the story of
sort of ai's like large language models
is so what's the normal thing to have
happen so in a large language model you
might have a prompt and then you're
asking well what's the normal thing
what's the reasonable text that you
might continue that with and that's kind
of the story of many many types of uh of
uses of of large language models and and
Ai and machine learning in general is
kind of what's the reasonable way to
continue things I think another type of
and so the same is true with videos uh
with with the kind of in the in the
sensor cases again it's kind of like is
that surprising or not you know the fact
that something weird happened you know
that these sensors recorded this value
is that surprising or not what can we
learn from from that you know I think
another place where kind of AI is an
interesting question how it's going to
work out is in kind of doing sort of
Natural Science kinds of computations of
of what's going on like a an example
being protein folding where it's not
obvious that the uh that the way that
the um uh the way that kind of a a
protein folds up is something that
there's any reason to think that for
example a large language model should
have anything to say about it I mean a
large language model a neural net it's
based on the same kind of sort of
fundamental architecture as our brains
and it's something where it's kind of
got these neurons just like our brain
has neurons in it and so the things that
we can do like produce language or
recognize images it's sort of
unsurprising that uh We've that we're
able to do that with an artificial
neural net it's a very non-trivial
scientific fact because it shows that
you know if we want to know what's
really going on in the brain it isn't
there isn't stuff going on that is sort
of bizarrely different from the things
that we capture in artificial neural
Nets but when it comes to using these
neural Nets to do things like figure out
how proteins should fold why should that
work it's not obvious it should work
it's not obvious I mean there are sort
of funny kind of self-referential
explanations like the things we care
about in the folds are the things we
notice in the structure of the protein
and those are sort of determined by our
minds by our brains I'm not sure that's
quite what's going on I think it's just
that these neural Nets are pretty good
at kind of just sort of filling things
in so it's kind of smooth in some sense
and that's kind of a good way to take I
mean in many cases in in the case of
protein folding what one's doing is one
saying let's look at the hundred
thousand proteins that we know how they
fold it up and let's take the protein
where we're being asked how's it going
to fold up and take and figure out what
pieces of that protein uh correspond to
the pieces of the of the protein The 100
proteins that we know about we know how
those pieces fold up now let's kind of
smoothly interpolate those things
together and that's really what the
machine learning is doing but you know
there are many other cases like kind of
mathematical calculations where we're
asking the question uh what
you know if we're if we're studying the
solution to an equation that might
represent a wave or something like this
or might represent uh then then the
question is how does that is there a way
of kind of shortcutting the kind of big
computations that one might do there by
just saying well let's see where the
neural Nets can figure it out kind of
like a human might say oh I've seen
something like that before it kind of
reminds me of weather forecasting where
kind of the the traditional version of
weather forecasting back in the day was
a meteorologist would say oh I've seen a
Hulk a cold front a hot front Etc I can
kind of match the pattern of what's
going on this is what I think the
weather will do that kind of gave way in
the 1980s and so on to the idea let's
just go solve the fluid equations on a
supercomputer and see what the weather
is going to do and that worked very well
now you can come back and say well
actually let's not do that let's just
look at historical data about weather
and let's use machine learning to
predict based on that sort of historical
data what's going to happen next I would
say that's probably an intermediate case
where it's not obvious which one is
going to win I think there are other
cases where it's very clear that the
kind of computational side of things
going to win other cases it's very clear
that they kind of just learn it from the
examples side of things is going to win
you know I think the another case people
talk about think about is in mathematics
now mathematics is a case which is
quintessentially computational so to
speak you know you want to figure out
how do you derive this theorem from
these axioms and so on well there's a
computational process it's kind of a a
thing where you have precise rules you
just follow through those precise rules
and so on and that's how you figure it
out that part of it I think is deeply
computational and is really not sort of
an ai-ish kind of thing I think the part
that is more ai-ish is okay you can go
out you can figure out sort of all the
possible theorems you could make there's
an infinite number of possible theorems
that are correct theorems of some
particular area of mathematics defined
by certain rules and so on the question
is which theorems will we humans care
about and that's a question that is much
more in the kind of the neural net do
something that's a sort of a model of a
human kind of thing to figure out what
what happens with and so that's a place
where I kind of think that guiding sort
of the the uh you know what what
theorems do we care about is more likely
to work now now people wonder about
whether it's possible you know when you
do sort of theorem proving and so on in
an automatic way there's kind of many
pods you could take and it's like do you
take the correct path and can you guess
by sort of intuition by heuristics by by
experience can you guess what you know
what path is the right path to take
um and that's that's something which I I
would say I consider the jury is still
out on whether that's going to work or
not
uh
so doing had also asked about training
multimodal AI models I think one of the
interesting things there is is there a
an intrinsic notion of meaning about
things that is independent of the way in
which we sense those things so we see we
hear we read
a concept a dog whatever else is the
intrinsic dog meaning something that is
somehow encodable in a neural net or not
brains in a way that is independent of
the mode by which that that meaning came
in my guess is yes there's a there's a
reasonable way to have a kind of a
multi-modal kind of representation of a
dog or something now you know then then
you ask the next thing that's sort of
the feature of neural Nets is neural
Nets are an idea where you grind up any
data you have and you turn it into
arrays of real numbers arrays of
continuous numbers in the whole idea of
computing has been you take everything
in the world and you turn it into
collections of bits uh in the case of uh
neural netsues sort of more specifically
thinking about sort of these arrays of
uh of continuous numbers and the
question is is there when you when you
sort of break things down from all these
modes of input and you make them into
this kind of inner core meaning is that
meaning is the is the kind of
representation of that core meaning in
terms of arrays of numbers what is that
like is it uh is there something where
you can say well I'm going to change
these numbers just a tiny bits and it's
going to change the meaning only a tiny
bit or will it will it be the case that
you change some of these numbers it'll
suddenly jump from being a dog to a cat
I just was studying this a little bit
and there definitely are jumps
um but it's a it's an interesting
question what the kind of structure of
that meaning space is and for example
I've just been talking about what I call
inter-concept space if you think about
all those different possible meanings
represented by these neural Nets with
all the different numbers in them
there's a place where those numbers
correspond to the cat concept there's a
place where those numbers correspond to
the dog concept but then there's an
inter-concept space just like we have
interplanetary into Stellar space and so
on there's a place between the features
we know that's kind of inter-concept
space where we have things which which
we've never seen before as humans that
they're things that were not Concepts
we've ever come up with but they're
things that we kind of see on the
journey from one concept we know to
another concept we know and exactly how
that works what's on that Journey are
there big surprises on that Journey that
are very different from the things at
the end well I've been studying that a
little bit and uh it's it's a little uh
there are some surprising things there's
some things that are very hard for us
humans to interpret and we don't really
have uh kind of whereas a loss for words
and that's not surprising because we're
an inter-concept space and the concepts
correspond to to words and we're in a
place where there aren't yet words so to
speak
so let's see
Daniel asks in person again uh do you
think we have reached a point of
Singularity such that any child born
from today onward will never be able to
surpass AI at any intellectual task I.E
are we the last useful generation
interesting question I think that here's
the thing
the computational universe is very
infinite you know we talk about that in
our physics project in terms of the
ruliad the kind of entangled limit of
all possible computations that's uh kind
of what's there of computational
possibilities is very infinite it's also
in a sense it's both infinite and
nothing because it is everything so to
speak it's it's sort of both the
representation of everything and
therefore in a sense there is nothing
unique about what it is a unique thing
but there's nothing that we can carve
out of it and say you know kind of
that's our special thing I think the
role that we humans have with respect to
the sort of computational universe with
respect to the rouliad for example is to
say what are the things that we humans
care about we each have a certain thread
of experience that is that is kind of
what our mind carve sort of uh follows
through time and I think that that
that's the thing that is sort of the
unique and significant thing about us is
our kind of thread of experience if you
say our experience will be generalized
to everything we no longer have this
kind of coherent existence as as
entities so to speak so I think when it
comes to the species as a whole there's
this question of there's a lot of stuff
that's computationally possible there's
the choice the unique and perhaps
significant choice of what parts of
what's computationally possible that we
explore and I think that's that's the
place where I think you know we humans
still haven't necessarily have a place
the rouliard is out there it's doing all
possible computations it's already won
the game it's already doing everything
there's nothing whatever we might do in
our kind of developments of our
civilization and being more
computationally sophisticated and so on
that's already happened the rouliad is
already out there doing all those things
so we are the thing that we have to
provide to it is merely that our sort of
our threat of experience our place you
know we are we are uniquely visiting
those parts of the rouliad that we visit
and that's significant to us that's kind
of the the key thing that we're
providing now you see that at a very
practical level you see kind of uh when
uh when it comes to you know jobs people
do people you know there'll be a wave of
automatic nation that comes through was
some job but people people always used
to be plowing fields or whatever else
and and everybody kind of had to plow
Fields there were fields to plow but
then that got automated and instead of
everybody turning to doing another thing
what instead happened is a great variety
of different tasks got done by people as
if what was happening was the the
frontier was always people picking what
parts of what's possible they were going
to pursue and I kind of think that will
happen again as we see sort of more
automation there'll be more kind of uh
sort of choice about what we choose to
do now remember we already lost the game
in some sense or the ruly had already
won the game because it's doing
everything and that's you know we win
our sort of future of our civilization
we gradually get to sort of explore more
and more of this really ad but it's
already doing everything so the thing
that is going to be significant to us is
the things that we choose to explore so
to speak so I think it's it's a it's a
thing where the the usefulness of us
humans has to do with the our
particulars of History so to speak it's
not the case there's no sort of perfect
sort of future of of humanity that gets
to sort of be the everything you know by
the time you are the whole rouliad you
are in a sense nothing interesting your
your you know there's nothing special so
to speak so I think it's kind of a a
what is significant in the future
becomes partly
a story of of the uniqueness of our
history and that's what is significant
to us now you you can say well I don't
you know I want to just go General I
want to sort of go ruliad so to speak
and and then well then you've lost kind
of human elements and at that point yes
it's kind of you could say well let's
just we now know about the rouliad we
can just sort of hang up our humanness
and forget that and just say okay the
universe is doing its thing uh you know
it's going to do everything we don't we
you know no no points in us being around
so to speak but I think that's um uh
that that's the um uh
uh that that's that's kind of my view of
of that um Direction I think that um uh
uh you know this question about
um uh to what extent kind of the um uh
the intellectual tasks we do
um the uh
um I have to tell people who are
actually here to if you unless you want
to be on audio you uh shouldn't um
uh shouldn't
yeah
um it's um
yes the um
now even even more fun will be if we can
actually do an interactive discussion
but I'm not sure we have quite the
technology or set up to do that in a
good way here
um but any case the the um uh you know
Daniel asks are we sort of the last
useful generation because everything
Beyond us can just be done by AI my my I
mean I think there's a way in which we
may be a very very useful generation in
a different way because uh you know it's
a question of when when more things
become possible when it becomes easier
to do more things there will be a
question of well what is really the
essence of humanity what are the things
that humans choose to do because they
are constrained by sort of the features
of the human condition and now is the
time when we're recording
through live streams and many many other
uh channels lots and lots about how we
are choosing to lead our lives and so on
and that's the thing where so we know a
lot about the choices people are making
today and in the future when people say
now we can do everything so to speak
what should we choose to do what would
the actual humans do then it may be that
we get end up looking back at our times
I mean it's it's not dissimilar to
what's happened in the past with with
you know kind of lots of religious texts
that came from a few thousand years ago
where people said at those times people
really knew what it was like to be human
so to speak let's look to those kinds of
uh of lessons so to speak for for what
happens today
let's see uh
these areas asking remotely
um is VR the future of of of uis of user
interfaces
um I don't know uh you know I think my
impression is that this kind of the
whole headset thing it's very dependent
on how good the hardware actually is
um you know whether the Thing Really
Works it's kind of like doesn't do you
any good to have a telephone if nobody
can really hear what you know if you
keep on saying what did you say what did
you say that's not a very good telephone
experience it's not a very good uh you
know the the uh the early personal
computers
um the the kind of the the the graphics
was not a I mean at least for me as a
kind of person try to use these things
you know I wanted the big fancy
computers because I I wasn't going to be
able to see very much on a little screen
like that my impression is that we
probably reached the point where we have
kind of uh human Vision level kind of
access to displays and that VR would be
pretty useful for that in that regard so
for example what's you know there's a
question of how good does audio have to
be before it's like as if you were there
so to speak you know our ears have like
50 000 nerve fibers going from our ears
to our brains our eyes have like 10
million nerve fibers you need a certain
level of data going to your ears to be
able to have audio that sounds like you
were there you need a lot more data to
go from your eyes to your brain to have
video that seems like you were there and
one of the biggest things has been
um that uh
um the uh
um uh that
um
uh We've we've got um
um uh the the
um uh I'm distracted here because we're
we're
um uh okay the the um
um one of the sort of big issues is our
field of view
uh when we look at a display we're just
looking at this little thing that's in
front of us uh our sort of natural field
of view is much larger and so one of the
issues is
um sort of can we have a display and
that was sort of a big deal with early
VR was we could actually have a head
mounted display but we actually saw out
to I don't know 135 degrees or something
I forget the exact exact number what the
kind of um uh what the kind of uh uh you
know we could we could experience things
including our peripheral vision and so
that's a thing that now there are just
about now high enough resolution
displays that we can kind of feed every
nerve fiber and gets to the periphery of
our vision and then haven't as if you
were there kind of video experience and
I think that will probably be
significant and I I do think that sort
of the next generation of of kind of uh
VR AR kinds of uh interfaces will be at
least really good as a way to not have
to have your computer screen sitting in
front of you you know you'll be able to
have your many computer screens floating
in front of you now I have to say back
in and sort of in terms of future of
technology I have to say it was probably
back in maybe 1979 that I first saw a
window interface for a computer
graphical user interface for a computer
based on Windows I happened to visit
Xerox Park where that was being
developed and I was like how can this
possibly work you know you've got weird
things like you're trying to move a file
from here to here and one window might
be obscured and then you can't get to
the other one you're going to make this
whole mess of pieces of paper on a desk
and that was a really messy thing and
you know how can this possibly work but
I was wrong it works pretty well you
know now the question is as we see the
kind of you know in in VR we see kind of
you know I've got Windows all around me
and I've got you know all these the
window on the floor a window on the
ceiling I've got little Post-its or all
around me so to speak I don't know what
that's going to feel like it might feel
very messy but then we're kind of used
to that with with sort of on-screen
desktops and so on
um I don't know I think that there's a
sort of interesting question I've
thought about this like a decade ago
this question of how do you do selection
and you know do you do it with your
fingers do you do it with your eyes uh
you know I think in and now there's
there's pretty good eye tracking from
from uh
um and and that will be a thing that
will be significant I think in in VR is
sort of how do you say I want that thing
over there
um and uh you know how do we how do we
sort of point to it and so on I think
that's um uh that's a uh it'll be
interesting to see how well that works
my guess is that there will be ways
found to make that work really quite
well I mean the idea of menus uh on a
computer in the graphical user interface
that was an idea that had to be invented
so to speak required the idea of a mouse
a pointer of some kind you know these
things had to get invented once invented
they turn out to be pretty intuitive
it's not obvious you know when you say
what do we humans what are we humans
used to doing and you then say well what
kind of interface can I make based on
what we're used to doing I think that's
a more difficult got thing you end up
inventing the interface and then people
get used to it I mean another interface
people have often talked about is kind
of as I kind of gesticulate around here
as kind of the gesture-based interface
it's usually whenever people start
talking about gesture-based interfaces
the movie Minority Report comes up
because that's a place where people
really saw those gesture-based
interfaces being used I have to say I'm
not sure that I've yet seen kind of
convincing use of gesture-based
interfaces but maybe with with VR
um with higher quality VR that that will
happen I think the real question is you
know they're they're different things
like you know I wear glasses you know
the glasses are not cool in some way
um but you know by the time everybody
has an augmented reality system glasses
will be cool again
um at least until there are kind of AR
contact lenses or something like that
um but you know and similarly the idea
of sort of going around with a great big
thing on your head is uh is kind of not
necessarily cool people are not
necessarily comfortable to lots of
people and you know the question is how
good does it have to get before people
are prepared to do that you know I
myself have been uh I've always liked to
uh uh sort of I walk around for you know
a couple of hours every day and I you
know I'm I'm used to kind of figuring
out oh I can have a treadmill or I have
a computer and I can type on the
computer while I'm using the treadmill
and I back in the 1990s I kind of had
this Vision where I'd be walking outside
and in a nice natural setting and I
would be using some kind of augmented
reality and I was kind of investigating
chord keyboards as a way to be able to
type while I was walking along and you
know it's now the 2020s and we're not
quite there yet you know the closest I
can get is to have some kind of weird
you know popcorn seller type rig where I
have a computer on it and I'm kind of
typing as I as I walk along which isn't
really so great or I can just be looking
at a phone if I'm not the one typing but
I think finally maybe within a year or
so maybe my 1990s Vision so to speak of
uh kind of going out and doing my walk
with a whole AR system will actually
come to fruition I'm not sure if it may
be one of these things to be careful
what you wish for because it may not
work out as well as I kind of imagined
in the 1990s it might work out I would
say also in terms of in terms of VR I
also back in the 1990s actually when VR
was was sort of a thing back then I mean
this is a you know I'm talking about
future of science and technology for me
it's always very useful to kind of see
something of the history of the future
so to speak and knowing things which
sort of seemed like oh this is going to
happen or oh we saw it in the science
fiction movies it's going to be this way
type thing VR is a thing which you know
seemed like it was absolutely just about
to happen at the beginning of the 1990s
and it really didn't for reasons I think
of of technology and hardware and so on
and you know as you turn your can the
accelerometer figure out kind of what um
uh what what you what you're doing from
there and I think um the
that's that's sort of a thing where it
gradually got better so to speak but but
um this you know it's useful to see what
happened to the things where we expected
something to happen and then what
actually happened often to me it's
easier to see what will happen than when
it will happen and one can be off by
many decades and when it will happen and
sometimes the question of when it will
happen is a very contingent question oh
there was this particular person there
was this particular company there was
this particular rather bizarre business
opportunity that made this be a thing
right then when it might not have
happened until 50 years later if if left
to other devices I think one of the
things back in the beginning of the 90s
I started thinking about kind of
network-based models of of space and the
structure of the universe and I was my
immediate thought was oh let's use VR as
a way to kind of pull through the
cobwebs so to speak and kind of
visualize this kind of network type
thing still hasn't worked out my in
experiments of about three years ago
when we were first launching our physics
project with VR we're not very positive
it wasn't very useful it wasn't it
wasn't something that actually fitted
into at least my kind of experience of
how things work I mean this is always
the challenge you can invent some
magnificent user interface which just
doesn't happen to connect with humans I
mean this is true with with you know we
we are pretty good with language so when
you come to a computational language
which is written out in terms of
word-like things we managed to
understand that if your computational
language is this complicated visual
thing that's a network where
everything's connected to everything and
so on we humans are not particularly
good at that it's not a particularly
good way to provide a human user
interface you know maybe it's a spider
interface if spiders are good at that I
don't know if they are but you know
maybe there's sort of an alien
intelligence where it is really good at
sort of untangling those kinds of things
but but we're not so to speak
uh
let's see is it question here oh boy
we've got lots and lots of questions
okay another one from someone actually
here Michael uh
given this this is this is going to be a
difficult one here given two contrasting
scenarios of a pink plasma heaven where
artificial general intelligence
optimally solves problems for all
sentient life and a matrix hell where AI
exploits humans as energy sources how
can we establish a guiding framework to
navigate between these extremes
um
you know I think
the
this so-called pink plasma Heaven that
you're describing where AGI solves
problems for a for sentient life I think
that may very well be a be careful what
you wish for kind of uh kind of
situation because it's kind of one of
these things where when there's nothing
to do things get very boring you know we
humans have a certain Human Condition
which has sort of certain uh you know we
we expect certain difficulties if we
don't have those we are we it's very
unsatisfying you know it's kind of like
the I could just hang out and and be uh
be happy so to speak but turns out that
doesn't work that way we even see that I
think when a very a very sort of almost
uh visceral level where people who do
deep brain stimulation and they're kind
of trying to sort of solve problems for
Parkinson's Disease and things like that
you'll you'll stimulate the brain even
right inside the brain in some way and
the Brain will habituate to that and
it'll say I don't care about that
anymore I want something new so we are
we are for whatever reason of evolution
of biological evolution what makes us
sort of The Human Condition be the way
it is in part is this desire to not have
things be too easy I think so it's you
know I kind of think that's to be
careful what you wish for now in terms
of the AI kind of having its own
objectives and saying ah those pesky
humans I can just use them as batteries
so to speak
um that's uh I kind of think that's a
that's a wrong thinking scenario because
I think you've got to realize there's a
lot that's computationally possible the
AI the machines will run they will do
what they do just as nature runs and
does what it does and the question is
you might say is nature taking advantage
of us well you know there are certain
kinds of Critters that wouldn't be happy
Critters unless there were humans that
built cities and put garbage out and so
on it's uh you know nature at many
levels is affected by us you can ask the
question are we kind of uh are we the
victims of nature taking advantage of us
I think that it's kind of a a um
it's some
it's something where I'm not sure that
it's you know that this description of a
thing where the AIS are doing their
thing and they're kind of taking
advantage of us I'm not sure that's a
concept that that necessarily makes
makes perfect sense I I think that this
question of do the AIS do a lot of stuff
we don't want them to do
well yes that's an interesting and
important issue I've been thinking about
that a bunch recently of kind of how do
you how do you set things up so that you
can make the AIS do the things we want
and not the things we don't want
um I think that at some level the ai's
become a bit like systems in nature
where they just do what they do and we
have to kind of do natural science to
try to understand what they're doing we
have to try and fit in and figure out
how we can find those caves to get out
of the rain or whatever else it is and
we have to find ways to exist within
this framework that is defined by by
sort of what happens in nature or what
happens in in sort of AI nature but I
think um it's um
this question of sort of how do we want
to guide it where do we want to go uh
you know do we want to go you know we
could decide in in terms of nature We
could decide we really need to live at
the bottom of the ocean
it's really hard for us to live at the
bottom of the ocean we'll get you know
we'll get nature is providing that
possibility but it's really hard for us
to go there I think sort of the same
kind of thing can happen with AIS
there's a sort of a thing that is
computationally possible but it isn't a
very good match for us and we have a
hard time kind of interacting with that
let's see uh Rob also here
um asks does the structure emerging from
the physics project give an insight into
the internal workings of our Labs
there's several people in our summer
school working on kind of llm science as
one might call it maybe it should be
called AI science I'm not sure it's the
natural science of llms it's llms are
are weird things to do natural science
about because they're really pretty
complicated it's kind of like what is
the natural science of human knowledge
for example that's been a thing about
which there's been a bit done on the
kind of Global Science of human
knowledge you know Aristotle was big on
the kind of Global Science of human
knowledge inventing things like logic
writing down lots of encyclopedic kinds
of things we haven't been so you know
we've been much more of a specialized
species so to speak more or less ever
since and so the idea of a global
science of human knowledge has been
something that hasn't really been uh you
know hasn't really been thought that
much about llm's kind of a front and
center saying Hey There is potentially
sort of a a global bulk science of
things related to human knowledge and
it's a really interesting thing to study
can our physics project help I strongly
suspect so I think that uh when it comes
to kind of what's the structure of sort
of the space of what amounts to meaning
space what's the structure of the space
that is created by what the llms are
doing I suspect there's a way of
thinking about that in terms of what we
think about in terms of the structure of
physical space I certainly think that
the sort of quantum llm the llm which
has many possible paths that it can
follow that thinking about sort of the
quantum llm which is kind of the the you
know normally an llm says okay I'm gonna
it has a certain amount of text it's
going to pick the next word it has a
whole ranked list of possible next words
and it will just pick either the the you
know it'll pick some word that's one of
the top words that's usually a little
bit with a bit of Randomness it'll pick
the next word it'll go on and pick the
next next word after it runs again and
so on but you can imagine what we would
call in our physics project A multi-way
system that shows all the possible
choices of words at this step then they
lead to new choices of words at the next
step and so on and that's kind of like a
Quantum llm and you can ask questions
about sort of what's the relationship
between different Quantum branches in
our physics project we have this idea of
branchial space this thing that relates
kind of the different possible branches
of history of the universe and I suspect
that those kinds of ideas can be applied
to llms and maybe some folks at our
summer school here will be will do that
um and so yes I think that that's a
that's an interesting thing but I mean
it's been kind of a I would say maybe in
the future it will be seen as a bit of
embarrassment but there was a a 2000
year Hiatus between sort of Aristotle
studying the kind of global structure of
of meaning and knowledge and what we
kind of got forced to study because we
can see that llms somehow do some of
this stuff but but kind of going in and
saying what's the natural sign events
it's like what are the kinds of
questions you can ask I mean you can in
many areas one of the things that's most
important in launching a science is
knowing sort of what basic question you
can ask like for example Natural History
1800s it's like there are all these
different kinds of Critters you know
maybe I don't know how many were known
then hundreds of thousands nowadays it's
millions of different kinds of Critters
that sort of populate the Earth and then
you could say well what can we how can
we say something scientific about all
these Critters you know they're ones
with four legs six legs they're ones
with fur they're ones with uh you know
with wings etc etc et cetera what is the
science that we can say now Linnaeus had
already figured out a certain amount of
that by being able to classify those
different kinds of organisms but then
the sort of big science result was you
know Darwin and the Origin of Species
and the idea of natural selection and so
on and that was a place where one could
now take this hugely diverse collection
of things that one saw and have some
general theoretical principle about it
and I think the same kind of thing is
what we can expect to see in kind of the
whole sort of span of human knowledge
that's represented in llm
let's see Luhan asks also here to what
degree do you think LMS provide us with
insights on the internal working of our
brain do you think there's more lessons
to learn from the structure of the human
brain when designing the next generation
of lolabs
I think that's an interesting question
and I think that llms
uh sort of I don't think the impact of
llms is yet fully absorbed in
Neuroscience I think in Neuroscience
there was always the question what's
important in the brain you know you
dissect a brain I've never done it I've
I've never you know I'm always impressed
when people say I've held the brain I
would I'm way too squeamish to ever do
something like that but anyway the the
you know brains are full of uh you know
a um
a hundred billion neurons human brains
at least and lots of other kinds of
cells and there are all kinds of things
happening and there are all these little
dendritic spines and maybe they twitch
and maybe they have Quantum effects and
maybe there's little vesicles of
neurotransmitter maybe it matters you
know down to the shapes of the vesicles
and so on what matters in determining
this thing we call thinking well I think
what llms have shown us is something
quite surprising in some ways I mean I I
I'm not that unexpected to me for
example but but in general quite
unexpected that it's all just like
neural Nets it's not there isn't a
little twitching Quantum spine there
it's really important to being able to
do this sort of human activity of being
able to generate language or doing be
able to generate certain kinds of of
linguistically based human thinking so I
think it's a very important data point
that there's less you don't have to
worry about you know the effect of the
glial cells on whether you say this word
or that word you don't have to worry
about some kind of quantum effect in the
way that human the way that grammar of
sentences works that's a really
important result now how do you go on
from there well you know the the it's
it's not clear that you know studying an
alarm is a lot easier than studying a
brain you know brains we don't yet have
the way to record from Individual
neurons with humans we don't get to do
that anyway because we don't really want
to you know
untangle our you know our brains so to
speak the the um it's uh it's a thing
where we get to see what's going on much
more clearly and then the question is
how similar are the phenomena that
happen in our lives to ones and brains
seems to me they're very similar there
are a lot of things about the way
learning works you know space repetition
as a as a strategy for human learning
for llm learning lots of kinds of things
about the ways things forget the ways
things learn from few examples and so on
these are very human-like there are very
many phenomena here that seems to be
very human-like now you know when it
comes to human psychology and whether
you take you know the a Freud level you
know super Egos and so on Theory or
something else the analog of that AI
psychology is a field that doesn't exist
yet but it will and there will be sort
of a global understanding of of the
psychology of AIS just as there's some
level of global understanding of human
psychology I think the real challenge
for both neuroscience and llm science is
sort of the same challenge which is you
know you know in Neuroscience you know
what the individual neurons are doing
and llm science you know what the
individual neurons are doing the
question is is there a higher level
description of what's going on below the
level of just well the llm says this or
the person says this is there a kind of
a narrative science that can be made at
an intermediate level in both
neuroscience and LM science llms give us
a big leg up on being able to do that
they don't give us a kind of Slam Dunk
result because they have the same issues
as brains have there's lots of neurons
there's lots of things they're doing a
lot of different things they have the
potential they expose the Natural
Science to us in in a better way now you
know I have to say one could imagine a
natural science of computers as well
people you know people usually don't do
that you run a computer and it does what
it does and you're looking for
particular output but when you say let
me like like for example back in the day
I don't know whether that still works
but you could take a an old analog radio
and you could put it next to a computer
and you would hear it going you know
all kinds of all kinds of sounds as it
picked up various kinds of electronic
emissions from the computer and that
would be something where you could um
kind of
you could uh that was a way in which
sort of there's a there's Telemetry from
what's Happening inside the computer but
and you could imagine a natural science
where you could say I recognize that
what the computer is doing it is
generally doing this because I can hear
this word sound
most of the time one doesn't do that
with computers most of the time that's
not how one thinks about using computers
my own efforts in kind of studying
simple programs and what they do are
much closer to a natural science of
computation of just seeing what happens
in a computer and there's a certain
amount one can say there these different
classes of cellular automata behavior in
general all these kinds of things but
that's sort of a a a different story but
no I think I mean in terms of whether
there is inspiration from from brains
for a Lambs I suspect the answer is yes
I suspect that there are some sort of
Hardware features of brains where we get
to you know learn as we think type thing
rather than having to have a separate
training phase from uh from a thinking
phase so to speak now whether we really
learn as we as you know whether whether
that really works or whether we're just
buffering things up and then you know
maybe when we're asleep we reconstruct
the memory structure it isn't really
known but there probably are some things
we can learn from kind of the uh the
human brain case that are relevant to
llms
um I think we we've already you know the
big thing we've learned is we just took
the output of lots of brains and we fed
that in as the training data for the
llms
see
um
zombo asks also here does the spread of
llms incentivize scientists and humans
in general to become more deeply
specialized to out-compete LMS in a
narrow domain or to become more broadly
spread in order to creatively generate
connections between apparently remote
domains
I I strongly think that there will be a
push for more uh generalists than
specialists in the future I think that
llms and AI in general computation in
general uh computational knowledge just
makes it possible to get specialized
things done much more automatically and
efficiently than we've been able to do
before and the things that are still for
us humans is the choice of what do we
want to do and that's really a much more
generalist kind of thing where you have
to know about all these different things
to say I want to go in this direction I
want to start investigating llm science
rather than just well I'm in an
electrical engineering department I'm
going to study electrical engineering so
to speak you know this this choice of
what to do is something for which one
has to have kind of broad knowledge so I
I really think that's the direction that
things will go
uh
uh we're getting all kinds of funky
things here Brad is asking will it be
possible to use llms to achieve world
peace or if World Peace isn't big enough
can we beam llm chats into outer space
to try to get Universal peace I think
that's uh that's wild
um the uh
you know I think uh the um this question
of sort of um
um you know how do we keep the humans
happy and uh prevent them from fighting
with each other you know one of the
issues is scarce resources and the
question is if if one feature of
computation is it's not scarce there's
sort of infinite computational universe
that you can mine and there's an
infinite amount of stuff out there and
you're not going to run out of
computation it's all there's always more
there you don't have to worry about
running out it's not like you know
um uh you know uh hunting squids or
something and the squids you run out of
squids
um you end up with uh you know that
computation is an infinite resource
available to sort of to everybody
but there's always there's still always
some sort of scarcity for example
there's scarcity and physical space
we're on this planet well maybe we can
go hang out on other planets as well but
there's also scarcity conceptual
scarcity like are you the first person
who gets to the the peak of Mount
Everest or whatever else are you the
first whatever that sort of by
definition is a scarce thing now you
know then the only question is well of
these scarce things what do we actually
care about maybe you can say I was the
person who got the very first copy of
this book that came off the off the
print run people don't usually care that
much about that unless it's an
antiquarian book in a very special
situation people don't you know there's
some things people care about there's
some things people don't care about sort
of defining what people care about is
sort of what defines what counts as
scarce and I suspect that's the you know
when we you know when there are
conflicts maybe maybe we're maybe we're
just built to have conflicts because
after all for the for the history a
biological evolution it was as Darwin
put it you know the survival of the
fittest in the struggle for life so to
speak we've been we've had 2.6 billion
years or three billion years or whatever
it is of of habituation to conflict and
maybe that's part of the human condition
just as uh kind of the the the seeking
the new and not wanting things to get
too easy as part of that so I think it's
it's kind of a um uh I'm not sure that's
part of the human condition you say well
let's get rid of that let's uh let's
remove that part of the human condition
well again so be careful what you wish
for type thing because maybe by removing
that part of the human condition and
saying everybody's going to be peaceful
all the time it's like everybody's kind
of the Drone all the time and uh you
know that's kind of the end of history
and so on but I think in um so I'm not
uh I wouldn't I wouldn't count on uh you
know given The Human Condition I
wouldn't count on llms being kind of or
AIS in general uh there might be
situations in which you know okay as a
practical person existing in the world
running companies things like this uh
you know I often see situations where
it's kind of like it looks like there's
two you know two things that are just in
total conflict but then you have to have
an idea and when you have that idea
suddenly there isn't a conflict and
everybody's happy and it's all good but
you have to have that idea and so
insofar as it's a question of how can
you best have that idea that's a place
where sort of intellectual things and
AIS can potentially help you know is
there a solution to every kind of every
human problem well my guess is this
there's scarcity and so on where where
they're sort of by definition won't be a
an ultimate solution but it's perhaps
the case that there are more creative
things that can be done and maybe the
AIS will help with that
um
let's see
there was a question from uh hang on
what do you think of power laws do you
think there are some sort of good entry
points for explaining the principles
behind power laws so just to remind
people power laws are things like oh I
don't know very very a famous one is if
you rank the words in English in order
of the frequency with which they occur
so the word the might in in spoken text
people always say I is the most common
word I'm not sure if that's really true
but but V and a and so on they're pretty
common words rhinoceros is less common
uh kind of uh something like
antidisestablishmentarianism is probably
even less common you can kind of rank
the words in order of the frequency see
with which they occur and there's a an
observation that the the nth most common
word has frequency about one over n so
that's a that's an example of a power
law it's the the the the that that's a
that's a pretty common example there's a
bunch of similar things with the the
distribution of incomes or something if
you rank them in a country the uh you
know you'll see the same kind of
distribution and so on uh different
Power law but same kind of same kind of
idea
um
the question why does this occur
I don't think I really know I mean there
are a lot of power laws Even in our
alums there are power laws there are
some sort of restricted cases where you
can see why it has to be that way
um but I would say as a sort of General
sort of the general source of power laws
I don't think I have a very good answer
to that there have been various efforts
to answer that
um my guess is that in the end and I
haven't thought this through properly my
guess is in the end the power laws exist
because the way that the kinds of
observations that we choose to make and
the kinds of things that we we choose to
measure so to speak lead inexorably to
that but I'm not sure about that it's a
good good question
Michael also in person asks what do you
think of the future of AI and video
games they can be used to control the
actions and dialogues of NPCs I guess
that's non-player characters
um the design of the game's world and
even the design of assets on the Fly
using little data but um uh let's see
video game assets take up a lot of data
we could use AIS to generate assets on
the Fly cut down the download size of
games as well as the effort needed to
make assets for sure absolutely going to
happen I mean you know using uh you know
there's been there have been experiments
on this for 25 years or more of games
where the sort of generative
procedurally generated scenery that's
been a thing for 30 years or more
um the idea of of sort of procedurally
generated characters uh is the thing
that a procedurally generated actions
for sure that's a that's a thing and uh
being able to have sort of more and more
sophisticated realistic scenery
generated by generative AI more and more
realistic kinds of behaviors on the part
of agents in the game for sure I mean I
I have I think that's a thing and now
the only question is at what point do
you care whether the thing you're
battling is another human or an AI at
what point do you say you know I'm
having a good enough experience without
any humans in the game so to speak where
it's a pure AI now obviously there are
games where there aren't other humans
but there are many multiplayer games and
Virtual Worlds and so on where people
are really uh sort of seem to be very
interested in the fact that there are
other actual humans in the picture but I
think an interesting question might be
at what point do you not care whether
the thing that you're interacting with
is a human or an AI and that will come
up also for for tutoring in education it
will come up for various kinds of
therapy and so on where where you're you
know you're talking to your AI therapist
or you're talking to a human therapist
and do you care whether the thing that
you're chatting with is a human with
sort of human empathy or is it enough
for it to be an AI with AI empathy and
my guess is that in many applications
people will in fact get to the point
where they're they're okay with the air
I'm not sure about this I mean I think
it's a question of of let's take
education as an example will it be
important that you're sort of convincing
the human and the human is convincing
you of something in education the human
is recognizing that you learn something
or will it be enough that you have sort
of gamified Education where it's merely
an AI merely badges that are invented by
the AI that make you feel like you're
making progress I'm not sure
um
see we have a lot of stuff here and I it
shouldn't go on too much longer but um
uh the um
um
it's uh
let's see
um
yeah some uh Danielle is asking
um how might we be able in the future to
tell what we're seeing on screen isn't
AI generated anything we could do today
she says I think you might be a bot
um and uh
that's an interesting question I think
that the the kind of the provenance of
things that we experience will become
more important you know people have
looked to blockchain as a way to kind of
record the provenance of what you're
seeing what where did that come from
what I mean I know that sometimes when I
you know for for ages when I've looked
at science technology things I'll say
where did that come from it helps me
understand sort of the the context of
what's going on who were those people
where did they learn what they what
they're going to say here you know
perhaps we can expect to see more kind
of of the Providence of oh this person
showed up and they're on a live stream
and they're doing this that and the
other but actually we know that person
has continuity with the person who
walked into the room to do the live
stream and so on you know those kinds of
provenance historical provenance and
information will probably become more
significant there and more to the kind
of you know is it an AI now you know as
we think about kind of the principles of
AIS you know there are I've kind of
imagined this this world in which we
have to Define you know there are 200
principles you might pick about her eyes
work which might not be compatible with
each other and it's kind of like people
might have giant placards for you know
principle 11 or principle 75 or
something like this but one of the
principles along with things like must
every AI have an owner is must AI
declare itself must you have to say this
thing is AI generated now that's a
complicated thing because it's kind of
like saying this thing was made in Italy
what does it mean this thing was made in
Italy you know does it mean that every
sort of you know every atom of this
thing sort of Came From Italy recently
or does it mean that the final assembly
happened in Italy or does it mean that
the designer was in Italy you know there
are sort of rules about that in various
kinds of trade setups but you know
that's a question for AI does it you
know if you photoshop the background is
it AI if you had you know this or that
thing is in AI probably it would be
worthwhile to have sort of a
well-defined collection of hierarchy of
sort of levels of ai-ness just like for
self-driving cars there's kind of a
notion of these different levels of
self-driving this up to you know the
level five you can sit in the back and
just hang out and do something different
type thing I think that um uh you know
that's that's a that's another kind of
question of sort of the Declaration of
ai-ness of things and and perhaps that's
a you know that's one of the principles
one might think about following and you
know does an AI announce itself is that
one of the principles that we have for
AIS is AI announced themselves but it's
a complicated slippery slope because you
know does it have to announce itself as
an AI if it did a spell checking does it
have to announce itself as an AI if it
made up the original concept but then
the rest of it well that was just a
prompt for humans and then the humans
wrote the text
they
let's see maybe one or two more things
and then um
uh
Michael asks thinking in terms of
inter-concept space do you think there
is an approach to using technology to
develop a way that we may better
understand or gain experience to bridge
the gap of inter-concept space of what
we know and what we don't know
um the uh
uh it's some
that's an interesting question that I've
been recently thinking about to what
extent can we get kind of experience of
what we don't know about now in a sense
I've been working on those kinds of
things for a long time studying kind of
simple programs and what they do like
the the thing behind me is an example of
something made by a simple program and
the question is uh sort of more of the
question is can we sort of how do we get
an understanding of that if you just
plop yourself somewhere into into
concept space or into kind of rule space
of different kinds of rules if you plop
yourself into that it's pretty
disorienting it's like what the heck is
this you know I haven't seen anything
like that before I think we humans have
to have a certain degree of gradualism
you know we gradually we invent a new
word we start thinking in those terms we
invent something else in mathematics you
see it you know we find this theorem we
find another theorem from that theorem
find another theorem from that we kind
of increment mentally go from here to
there I think that's kind of a thing
that we have to do and and how can we
can we accelerate incrementally going
from here to there quite quite possibly
yes as we have AIS that can help us
learn how to learn and tell us what we
have to
um uh what we have to kind of um uh do
to to to learn the next thing I think
that that's um uh that's the thing but I
I think this kind of question
let's see I mean who will write the
textbooks into concept space so some
random part of rural space that textbook
has to go lily pad to Lily Pad so to
speak it doesn't get to be the the alien
textbook that's just out there in sort
of you know that that's why the
extraterrestrials so to speak that's why
alien intelligence is kind of a hard
concept to deal with because it's like
by the time it's alien enough it just
doesn't relate to us we just can't can't
sort of communicate we can't we can't uh
map our version of intelligence onto
onto its version of intelligence I think
um uh yeah so I I mean this question of
how do we how do we expand our kind of
domain in rural space how do we how do
we learn what we don't know about the
first thing we have to do is recognize
that there's stuff out there that we
don't know about that's a big part of my
new kind of science effort and ruliology
and studying what simple programs do is
yes there's a lot of stuff out there now
there's a question of do we care about
it can we example make technology that
we think is cool and useful based on
exploring those kinds of things and
that's kind of a a long time challenge
of mine
uh
see
just going to um
[Music]
ah I'm being told I need to
get going and um in a moment but uh
um okay maybe we end with this uh David
who's here uh says some uh when will the
statement I think you might be a block
bot
be a compliment rather than a criticism
or an insult
um and uh that that's um
that's an interesting question I mean I
I think in um you know if I imagine
doing some computational kind of thing
you know doing a or no if if I imagine
you know doing some manual tasks I very
you know I'm learning how to do some
very precisely crafted thing I'm making
a a beautiful kind of thing that is very
precise so I'm landing a plane in a very
precise way and somebody says you know
boy was that you know was that Landing
done on autopilot
um you know in a sense perhaps already
that's a compliment so to speak in that
case that you achieved something that
was beyond the level of sort of
messiness that we humans normally
achieve I think when it comes to uh kind
of you know that was an idea that was an
intellectual development that was so
impressive that it must have been this
kind of you know this llm that knew
about all these different areas and
managed to pull them together you know
wow you're as good as another so to
speak yeah that might become a
compliment one day
um I think it's uh you know that's a
real question of of kind of a lot about
the future of humanity and lots about
what we you know what we aspire to
because there are a lot of things where
you know we might aspire to to being
able to do this or that thing and uh uh
you know then it turns out it's actually
easy to do that there's actually
technology that makes it easy to do that
and then we're like yeah that doesn't
matter we're interested in this other
thing that that is still hard to do and
I'm trying to think of an example where
where people have um well like like for
example
being able to run really fast
you know being able to go really fast by
running really fast back in the day it
was surely a very significant thing I
mean it's still significant but it's not
as significant to be able to be the
fastest possible Runner because you know
what you can get in a car and go much
faster than just running and so it isn't
as much a kind of a a badge of honor to
be able to do that now for us today
there has been well it's sort of a
dramatic thing that's happened with llms
for a while it's kind of being able to
spin up an essay about something being
able to write the the legal brief being
able to write this kind of explanation
of something that was a kind of Badge of
human honor but it is becoming less so
because llms can do that now and you
know there are other things that alarms
can't do that are still so these things
that get automated they might have
seemed significant in the past another
one another good example would be
calligraphy and being able to make sort
of very elegantly presented kind of
written things it's like that was a big
deal until there were fonts and so on
it's still a cool thing to be able to do
but it's not really the kind of big deal
that it was in the past and I think that
will you know as we Define what we think
is significant that will be defining it
to be those things that aren't the
things that technology makes easy and I
claim one of the things that that will
be inevitably not Made Easy by
technology is the choice of what it is
we decide to do which technology doesn't
have an intrinsic way to figure out and
so that's that's a um uh that's kind of
a a thing that is intrinsically human
because the general case of the general
rouliad that does everything is sort of
the case of nothing and insofar as we
sort of have an existence as humans it's
these choices that we make that are
significant and as I said I think that
the uh you know you did that as well as
a bot will be something that for
particularly as these things transition
from being things that only humans can
do and humans aspire to do them better
and better and better and then the bot
does them really really well it will be
for a while at least to compliment to
say you know you did that as well as a
bot so okay with that I should probably
wrap up here and um uh you know in the
future somebody can you know use this
live stream as a as a piece of uh
training data for a bot of the future
and can be amused by this um uh The
Botch can be suitably amused by my
statements about um you know the
compliments of he did it as well as a
bot all right thanks and bye to people
on the live stream and uh uh
thanks for being here in person guys